[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Sean Casey he doesn't get in a fight
with anybody MLB network analyst
three-time NL All-Star with the Reds
wait did you ever get into a fight in
your major league career
I did get into a couple fights DP uh I I
got to suspended twice but I was coming
into the fight I remember the first
fight I got into was
um remember Carlos Silva So Adam when
Adam Dunn first came up man Dunner was
like if you remember I'd have done you
know six five probably like 250 and I
remember him telling me one time he goes
Casey goes he used to play football
Texas he's like I'm coming for the
catchers you know I'm coming back and
I'm like man you know I'm like all right
for the first time I ever seen him hit a
catcher we're in San Diego he just gets
called up he's rounding third and I'm
behind the disc and I'm telling him get
down left down left
boom hits Wiki Gonzalez and like we
think Gonzalez is knocked out cold
Thunder runs to The Dugout I'm literally
over a weekend going bro oh are you okay
are you okay you know so that was the
first time I realized daughter was
coming for catchers so fast forward a
couple months later we're playing the
Phillies and he had to play with Mike
lieberthought the dish and kind of took
him out and it looked a little dirty to
tell you the truth I'm like that was a
little dirty I think right there you
know I mean so the next time he comes up
Silva throws behind him and I was like
all right guys we're getting ready to go
everybody on the top step like William
Wallace would be Braveheart time you
know what I mean so so
next pitch he drills Dunner and then
Dunner does the the cardinal sin of
going to get a picture he goes out
hesitates and then goes again
so when he goes again lieberthal had got
him from behind Danny and clips him and
then donor goes straight down and I go
flying out as fast as I could you know
that wasn't that fast
arms I'm out there like this running
like this you know bad technique I get
out there Carlos Silva comes up and I'm
like I'm gonna play Peacemaker I'm like
hey let's break it up break it up Carlos
Silva like six stunners heading the
ground and boom gives them one so now
I'm like five feet away I'm like change
your plans can I just come here bam I
end up hitting silver in the face next
you know it's we're all on the mound for
some reason for some reason we're all on
the mouth like this is a terrible place
to be next you know Danny I'm I'm on the
mountain next thing you know I'm
Airborne I'm like oh my God I'm Airborne
I'm like you got to be kidding me so
like someone has me and they're
launching me oh like it's freaking WWE
off the top rope off the mountain
um Airborne I'm just like oh
monster of a man grabs me and runs with
me and drops me and was the philly so
Placido Blanco's on the team he's like
Casey Casey are you okay are you okay at
the bottom of the comic I was like I
think I broke four ribs it turns out I
got three game suspensions though yeah I
got in there a little bit more uh if you
were gonna give a grade to Major League
Baseball for the first month of the
Season what would the grade be oh hey I
think it's today jobs any negatives to
the new rule changes
really negative I was saying
and he was getting a standing up base
they're like Cody Bellinger and he's
like yeah the place is going crazy 55
000 he's pipping his hat in the upcomes
I was like strike one oh my God
I'm the Umpire the umpire's got a call
timeout to understand the moment there
yeah yeah we gotta learn from that one
right there and say okay when a guy
comes back after winning championships
for six years he finally comes back and
gets a standing ovation let's let that
roll for a second you know I mean it's
good for the game okay you were a great
hitter how would you use the pitch clock
to your advantage
well I think uh well I was a message in
the Box remember then I stressed to the
left stretch Right double shoulder roll
a couple of these bad boys and doing my
gloves and I'm lifting my leg I would
have delayed have been like straight one
two three he's out of here
um trouble you would have had trouble
with this I think initially I would have
had to have like cleaned up my act a
little bit no doubt and so like yo get
in the Box quicker but I think the
advantage is in the in the hitter
picture matchup you know I think it's
like Hey listen you know there's not
much time to think about that next pitch
you know within eight seconds you have
to address that picture so I think
almost as an advantage sometimes I think
sometimes as a hitter if you're
especially on times where you're
struggling you're overthinking what just
happened you know was it a thinker this
could matter or man I just took a
terrible swing at a change if it looked
terrible in front of everybody I'm
getting booed no you don't have time to
think that like you got to just get your
breath get your process Tighter and get
in the box and and face uh you know the
action so I like that I like that it's a
little quicker I think it's good for the
pitcher and the header yeah Aaron judge
talked about that you don't have time to
think about the last pitch because you
got to be in the moment you got to be
present there we're talking to Sean
Casey MLB network analyst three-time
All-Star with the Cincinnati Reds and
maybe the only man who's ever been
thrown out of first base from by the
left fielder
it'll never happen again I don't think I
think I'm the only guy that'll happen
um give me the surprise team this year
man
um I think Minnesota
I think Minnesota soda has a real shot
with if Buxton you know Buxton dhn and
staying on the field I think that if he
could if you can get 145 games of Byron
Buxton swinging I think it adds so much
I think Lopez to the top of that line
top of that rotation is a huge piece
that kind of went went under the radar I
mean arise is a great player won the
batting title went to the Marlins just
doing his thing but I think Lopez at the
top of that rotation makes them better
Correa being back I think the twins you
know really have a shot to uh to do well
this year MLB network has shohei Otani
and the angels against Aaron judge and
the Yankees the next three days ohtani's
not going to be on the mound for these
games he he was uh pitching yesterday at
Fenway uh so tonight it's seven Eastern
and also Sean has a podcast the uh the
mayor's office if you ran the angels
what would you do with shohei Otani with
this next contract
the problem the angels
Angel's contact and the fact that Rendon
is signed to over 200 million dollars
and now you have a problem with are you
willing to have Otani you know we're
talking we could be seeing upwards of
500 million dollars for this contract
you already have these three guys in
your team you have a time you have trout
and you have Rendon
so if you add that payroll you know
they're having a tough time getting
pitching right now as it is so I if I'm
the Angels he's he's the best player in
baseball he it also is an international
Superstar so as far as making money at
the gate there's nobody that sells more
than Otani if I'm the angels I try to
bring them back I mean I try to I try to
find a way to bring them back knowing
that you know we have three guys now
that we we are promised some big
long-term deals but
Otani is just a different breed than
that but you're not winning with these
guys and I know Rendon has been injured
but a big disappointment you're I don't
want to say stuck with Trout's contract
but you know it hasn't produced anything
and it's not all on him obviously with
one baseball player but you're gonna
spend probably 600 million dollars on
shohei utani
right
what if you're out what if you're out of
the pennant race and it's mid-august
you want to I I don't know if you want
to keep doing the same thing you're
doing and spending all this money or you
could get the biggest haul in baseball
history now you'd be known as the team
that traded away shohei uttani and you
know but as long as he did not end up
with the Dodgers then you know that
would be that'd be even more
uncompounded but would you yeah would
you why would you give me a scenario
where you consider trading Otani I think
that the scenario would be that I mean
they're gonna really have to look at you
know if you let shohei walk and he when
it goes to free agency and you don't
sign him back and you let him walk
and he goes to LA or New York or
wherever he's you know gonna go the
Dodgers
um
you could you you're exactly right Dan
you have a shot at the deadline this
year you're actually getting an
unbelievable hallback of you could get
ready big league players that are legit
and also Frontline top prospects so this
is the one shot the angels have if they
think at all he's gonna walk a free
agency I almost feel like if the angels
are out of it at the deadline you have
to trade show hey what's the coolest
thing in your man cave
cool thing my man came all right uh I
got some cool stuff over it I think one
of the coolest things that I have is I
have a um uh a signed check by Joe
DiMaggio and a signed check by Marilyn
Monroe with a picture above him and I
just think it's cool it's a 1955 check
signed by Maryland can you can you take
it off the wall
all right hang on let me see okay
talking to Sean Casey MLB Network okay
here we go all right show and tell all
right you guys see it so it's the
magazine DiMaggio Marilyn Monroe getting
off a private jet back in the day when
they used this is why mark
what what's the check how much is it for
this check I don't know if Marilyn
Monroe was cheap or not but this checks
for a dollar and 55 cents that Marilyn
wrote
how did you end up with it
so and then this was the uh some school
DiMaggio wrote for 18 Grand that's a big
one I ended up with it because um the
baseball assistant team they have a um
they have a big fundraiser every year
where a lot of the Hall of Famers guys
come back to New York and I went I went
to it a few years ago I was in the city
you know working at the network and dude
Danny there was a huge snowstorm bro so
no one made it so next you know I'm like
I was bidding on everything I'm like
I'll take that I'll take that I think
but that's how I got it if anyone else
had made this thing no way this is at my
house but the fact that six guys showed
up is the reason I have this thing right
here
hey by the way uh congrats with your son
hitting a grand slam and uh that where
is he at Kent State Penn State he's at
Kent State yeah yeah man thank you
brother I tell you what there's nothing
like watching your kids play you know
playing at Kent State and doing well but
you know you're more nervous watching
them play Then you ever are by yourself
in the box and and his home run Trot is
faster than you sprinting
it's 560. I'm like I don't know where
you came from but definitely not my side
of the family you know good to talk to
you man thank thank you again Sean yeah
David great see you thanks for having me
on brother see you soon Sean Casey Mr
energy